james paxton who had that lower back
surgery early on in february started to
ease his way back from that really
struggled his first couple games giving
up eight runs in four innings but sunday
against tampa bay by far his best game
so far pilar leads things off for the
red sox today first pitch swinging and a
fly ball to center field for brett
gardner one pitch
one out
but the red sox are in business first
and second one out and here is the very
dangerous zander bogarts hit in the air
to right center on the run is frazier to
make a diving catch throws towards
second and it is just late
gardner and frazier were there frazier
though got there first
and made the catch diving frontward now
here's the the 1-1 and vasquez hits a
ground ball to second le mayhew will
touch up out second on the four
unassisted force and paxton pitches out
of trouble no runs two hits
really the one sure thing in the boston
pitching staff so far and his last
timeout john against toronto a
career-high 10ks and voight has a single
to center now here's geo urchella swung
on and in the air to deep right that
ball is high not as far it is gone
and the right field sees ashelah the
most happy bella
no
he's the most happy bella he is a
two-run home run to right and the
yankees take a two-nothing lead
2-17 with three runs batted in swung
online knocked down by paxton his glove
comes off paxton throws to first
terribly but the ball was caught
beautifully
by luke boyd what a weird play line
drive knocked the mid-off packs and
grabbed it threw it straight down and
boyd made a great pick and once again
the red sox have two men on here's jd
martinez now martinez swings and pulls
the line drive off for shimmer down the
left field line to tie the game
martinez chugging for second the throw
beats him he's out
but he's driven in two and it's 2-2 here
in the third so two way here is bogart's
but now we're all tied at two
there's a drive left field hit high and
deep back to the warning track is
talkman still going back he jumps it's
gone and the red sox lead 3-2 xander
bogarts hitting it over the auxiliary
scoreboard in left center field his home
run giving the red sox a 3-2 lead fourth
home run and 11th rbi for xander the
talkman is on players gary sanchez swung
on and hit high in the year to left
field that goes verdugo on the track at
the wall she's gone
a two-run home run for the sanchino
oh that gary is scary he hits a two-run
home run his second home run in his many
nights and the yankees take a 4-3 lead
so run us at first and third here's dj
and lemay you cut sam misses and
booney's gonna check and make sure that
lemay you didn't hurt his wrist but the
one hand came off the bat as he was
swinging
that's one guy you really don't want if
you're aaron boone to
have any issues looks like lemay who's
going to stay in there but it doesn't
look particularly comfortable he's still
kind of pacing around
hit on the ground too short little flip
the second to end the enemy tyler wade
has come into the game that means dj
lemay who is out the same week where
they lose giancarlo stanton they lose
aaron judge alba mahu who has been so
steady leaves the game now the eight
hitter fraser who's reached both times a
walk and a double second and third one
gone here he comes
swung on hit in the air to deep right
that ball is high it is far and it is
gone
clint fraser just walloped a three run
home run in the right field seats and
the yankees now take a
7-3 lead guardness swipes third it'll be
an o2 to wade hit on the ground base hit
into the shortstop hole wade heads
towards second the throw is not in time
a hustle double for weight that's a
single but they didn't field it right
away and wade has great speed and is
very aggressive so it's an rbi double
for weight on the ground ball through
the shortstop hole yankees already up
8-3 and got the bases loaded and one man
out line base hit left field one run
scores archela here comes tockman well
clint frazier is doing it owl that's a
two-run base hit he's knocked in five
runs with three hits and they have first
and third and one man out there's a fly
ball to left
sanchez to tag verdugo for the catch and
here comes gary will score easily it's a
sac fly and an rbi for gardner and the
yankees now take an 11-3 lead alex
verdugo leading off there's a swing and
a deep drive right field way back and
gone alex ferdugo goes deep and it's
11-4
fifth home run of the season
for the red sox
left fielder so not finished yet 11-5
ground ball right side and the yankees
do it to the red sox again 11-5 this
time they've won all five meetings
between the teams this season